hello and welcome to this video playing
Dexter Morgan here with black let's see
after all right I played it five times
five wins it sounds good let's make it
six out of six III that's that's early
interesting
I wonder if I can wait try something
something a little bit creative try to
make you make more pressure against you
for TM isn't that an annoying pin down
on f3 how is he handling the situation
it's not so easy to get rid of even f5
comes into consideration let's let's go
fri feel right before now would actually
lose stuff and age three loses the h3
porn so my ideas hi def 795 night have
seven he might exactly play you for in
this movement maybe
can also keep this b5 option open I
don't don't really see what white is
doing in the next couple of moves he's
really tied down with the situation here
night f70 might play a form just in
exactly this moment it could work maybe
not but anyway I'm fairly flexible
threatening b5 now I think a form and
you should play now you cannot take
twice on b5 as then f3 would hang so
what why is that working Queen second
what is the deal hmm I'm okay so i can
now with slight variation why yes ok
yeah I can win win material now with
with various ways ef3 maybe as strongest
it does not have enough for the Queen so
let's see what happens so this that he
went III this is a bit unusual 93 is the
most obvious move but III is of course
not bad i'm not sure if night age six is
a good idea objectively but it it worked
quite well yeah this should be four and
i know i don't know if d5 now is right i
mean the situation looks extremely
awkward extremely awkward because he has
no natural way to unpinned us any age
three check just drops this pawn
and if he goes eform instead let's say
here then I have f5 again and this is
disastrous simplement c4 is also hanging
I could take this if everything else
fails I can take the pawn now ok this
one and they're five and now we can
never play you for extremely awkward
yeah that the engine wants to play this
move actually but I was not sure because
before but it seems that this doesn't
work ah it's cute I have this one check
winning a piece ok I didn't see that so
then then then this is a good move of
course I just play this and threaten 95
here it's extremely problematic the
engine now gives age 32 check yeah
jettison upon that here blankets is
clearly better with this pawn & a 6 a-6
is not as powerful but she doesn't
really have all that much that he can do
ok b5 was already already on but ok that
just drops everything yeah it was a very
bad opening result for white ok thanks
for watching